Das was ein forschungsteam des kernforschungszentrums
cern jetzt plant ist nicht nur exklusiv sondern auch äußerst riskant der transport von antimaterie in einem lastwagen
welches ziel dieses experiment verfolgt und wie
zerstörerisch dieser plan wirklich ist das jetzt bei steaks und science fiction ein video in zusammenarbeit mit technology review
zum schluss habe ich übrigens ein großes exemplar der wirklich kundschaft für euch herzlich willkommen
Das war damals vor 85 jahren eine echte sensation
die entdeckung der antimaterie seitdem wissen wir für jedes teilchen gibt es auch ein antiteilchen der elektronen
ist das zb das positron und nicht nur in der natur ist das zusammenspiel zwischen materie und antimaterie
von großer bedeutung heutzutage kann antimaterie sogar künstlich erzeugt werden und ist beispielsweise für medizinische
diagnosen äußerst sinnvoll der plan des cern physikers alexandra bertelli und seines teams aber lässt einem den atem stocken
eine milliarde
antiprotonen sollen in einem container gespeichert werden und einige hundert meter
transportiert werden um sie dann in einem anderen experiment nutzen zu können
konkret soll die antimaterie auf schwach radioaktive atomkerne gefeuert werden dieses experiment habe ein äußerst
zerstörerisches potenzial so die kritischen stimmen und
antimaterie ist eine echt exklusive sache dann nämlich wenn sie auf materie trifft auf der stelle löschen sie sich dann gegenseitig aus
0,5 gramm antimaterie würden dabei um reine energie zerstrahlen und auf einen schlag ebenso viel energie freisetzen
wie die atombombe fat man die hat im august von 45 die japanische stadt nagasaki
weitestgehend zerstört die atombombe hatte eine sprengkraft von
21 kilotonnen tnt entwickelt das ganze experiment verfolgt natürlich auch einen sinn
das cern forschungsteam möchte ganz konkret an die protonen mit neutronen und protonen zur kollision bringt und dann die entstehenden
zerfallsprodukte analysiert denn seit rund zehn jahren weiß man dass atomkerne nicht immer eine art klumpen aus neutronen und protonen
bilden sondern auch neutronen wolken auch halles genannt oder dichterin neutronen schalen das hatten forscherinnen und forscher beispielsweise
beim radioaktiven beryllium entdeckt das kommt an der cern experiment mit der antimaterie
könnte somit aufdecken ob es noch weitere solcher kerner geht im besten fall könnte sich damit sogar klären wie wir uns ihr innenleben
vorstellen können die herstellung von
antiprotonen ist für das cern an sich nichts neues das gelingt indem man schnelle protonen auf einen massiven metall blog schießt
elektromagnetische felder brennen sie dann stark sodass sie gespeichert werden können durch ein vakuum werden die antiprotonen dann von der umwelt isoliert
doch die von obertilliach gesteppte größenordnung ist mit nichts bisher dagewesene zu vergleichen bislang liegt der rekord von antimaterie
experimenten bei 10 millionen antiteilchen die man für kurze zeit gespeichert hat das jetzt geplante experiment dagegen sieht eine
milliarde vor wenn man das sehen das ist 100 mal so viel der forscher selbst sieht das gelassen ihre
animation also das zunichte machen würde seinen angaben zufolge nicht mehr energie freisetzen als man braucht um einen apfel hochzuheben
und weiter sei die radioaktivität die dabei freigesetzt würde
verhältnismäßig gering doch wie plant das cern forschungsteam überhaupt diese
gewaltige menge an antimaterie zu stellen und über einen zeitraum von einem monat zu speichern genau hier liegt die große herausforderung
aber terry und sein team wollen eine elektromagnetische falle bauen die 70 zentimeter lang ist
diese soll dann im inneren eines tonnenschweren
super leitenden magneten auf minus 269
grad celsius gekühlt werden das vakuum das verhindern soll dass die antiprotonen mit luftteilchen in berührung kommen muss dabei
100 1000 mal dünner sein als das des lhc
beschleuniger falls dem forschungsteam tatsächlich eine speicherung der
antiprotonen gelingt könnten diese in einem fahrzeug dann zum benachbarten labor transportiert
werden wo das anschließende experiment stattfinden soll denn wir in der benachbarten
isolde ionenstrahl einrichtung würden die antiprotonen dann mit den radioaktiven
ionen kollidieren oberteile und sein team die sind jedenfalls optimistisch die entwicklung einer solchen technologie könne ganz neue wege
in der forschung eröffnet beispielsweise sieht der wissenschaftler sie
zukünftig als
vielversprechende antriebsquelle für die raumfahrt
vielen dank an die redaktion von technology review für das spannende thema noch weitere unglaubliche
themen gibt es in dem gratis hefte dass er bekommt wenn er hier drauf klickt also klicken und staunen würde ich mal sagen und
hier geht es weiter also darunter mit einem anderen coolen thema von technology review dafür auch einfach drauf kriegen schutzhülle um das erbgut
werden wir zu superhelden bis dann
blatter